欢迎来到知行小酒馆，这是一档有知有行出品的播客节目。
我们关注投资，更关注怎样更好的生活。我是玉白。
前段时间我去欧洲旅行，有一个画面给我留下了很深的印象。
那是在一家餐厅门口，我站了很久，没有人来招呼我。
甚至，很多服务员经过对我视而不见。
一开始我特别想吐槽，觉得这服务太糟糕了。
后来当地的朋友和我解释说，这很正常。
因为领位是领位远的工作，其他人有自己的职责。
后来我慢慢观察发现，不只是餐饮业，那边很多人真的是只做自己职责内的部分。
不会随时待命，也不会处在一种眼里有活的状态。
那一刻，我有一点恍惚，只做自己分内的事情。
这不才应该是正常的工作状态吗？
可回到国内之后，这种恍惚很快就消失了。
手机消息还是不停的想，外卖还是要抓紧时间吃。
工作和生活之间的边界，也还是很容易被冲淡。
然后我就开始了思考，为什么明明技术在进步。
工具越来越高小，社会也在往前走。
可我们却没有因此变得更轻松，反而越来越忙，越来越累。
后来我在小红书上看到了一句话，大意是说，
很多生意本质上赚的是人们疲惫的钱。
当时我一下子就被这句话记住了。
对呀，外卖赚的不就是我们疲惫的钱吗？
很多及时满足的服务，很多效率工具，
某种程度上好像也都是在赚我们疲惫的钱。
可究竟是为什么？
社会看到我们每个人都这么累，
不是先想办法帮我们消除疲惫，
而是不断的利用这种疲惫，
去创造新的需求，新的产业，还有新的经济价值。
所以这期节目，
我想和小酒馆的老朋友文一飞老师好好聊聊这个话题。
看我们能不能从经济史，
从生产力和工作方式变迁的角度，
来解释这种普遍的疲惫。
我们有没有可能，不需要这么辛苦。
以及这背后，是不是藏着某种，
我姑且把它称作疲惫经济学的东西。
希望这期节目也能带给你一些新的理解。
这次聊天的契机其实是，
两个月前我跟一飞老师的一次谈话，
因为那个时候我刚从欧洲旅游回来，
就那次旅游也是我十个十年再一次去欧洲，
其实带给了我很多的冲击，
比如一上来让我感到不习惯的就是，
欧洲的餐饮业，
它的效率太低了，
而且服务太多，
就大家懂得都懂，
甚至我体验过一次，
我当时在柏林，
我说我要结账，
从我说我要结账，
到他真的给我结账，
中间隔了20分钟，
当时我就问了我当地的朋友，
他说这个其实很正常，
他们都习惯了，
因为他们每一个人的活是固定的，
每个人是单线程的工作，
这样互相不影响，
对劳动者来说也更轻松，
然后那个时候我就有一点恍惚，
我就反观了一下在国内，
我见到了各个行业的从业者，
没有人是单线程工作，
而且随着及时通讯软件的这么的普及，
你可能24小时你都是在线的，
然后回来我就跟一飞老师说，
这个有没有可能我们出一个选题，
从经济学的角度来研究一下，
就为什么我们会这么疲惫，
以及为什么休息，
尤其是在东亚地区仿佛没有正当性，
我有两个问题，
第一个是你刚才说的，
你在德国体验了那样的服务之后，
当时的状态是觉得会有点烦吗？
一开始会有点烦，
就觉得怎么这样，
然后想说这样的店我要洗小红书发铁壁垒，
第一反应是这个，
但是就像我说的我跟我当地的朋友聊过天嘛，
然后我就意识到说可能对于当地人这确实是个常态，
那我不妨就更多的去观察一下当地人是怎么生活的，
试图融入这个节奏，
所以到我旅程的后半段，
我就是每天也是睡到自然醒去看一个宅，
然后和我的闺蜜去吃个饭，
这个吃个饭可能就从12点吃到了下午三四点，
也没关系，
然后我们回家遛个狗看看电视，
我觉得也度过了非常愉快的一天，
就会发现其实也挺有趣的。
所以你回到中国之后你有没有感觉到那种冲击，
就是重新节奏回来的？
我当时在欧洲的时候，
我跟自己说，
我说中国的菜业实在是太好了，
大家的服务太都太棒了，
而且效率这么高，
我回去一定一条差评都不给，
然后回来之后一周后就变惯了，
一周后点外卖发现那个少了配菜，
我想说怎么这样我要投资，
对，所以当你是消费者的角度来看他的时候，
你是希望他更快，
然后质量更高，
然后服务得更妥贴，
我觉得这个是蛮有意思的一个情况，
就是为什么技术一直在进步，
生产力一直在发展，
劳动时间好像也没有在缩短，
实际上你说到这里我有一个很有意思的现象，
就是历代工业革命，
突然下车道这么一样，
对，历代的工业革命，
就是按道理是生产力进步最快的时候，
不论是蒸汽机、电力，
还是我们说第三次互联网信息时代的革命，
这些技术的大跨越的时代，
我们一般会想说会不会造成极大的失业，
会不会造成工作的减少，
结果实际数据显示，
往往在这个时候劳动强度是最大的，
第一次第二次工业革命就不说了，
那时候就是大规模的这种血汗工厂，
特别像英国工业革命的时候，
那时候工人完全没有什么福利，
小朋友可能10岁就开始工作，
活不了几年就会去世，
因为工作强度太大，
劳动环境太恶劣，
悲惨世界就那个状态，
然后到了其实二战前后从福特时代开始，
一直到70年代是一个生产力仍然在进步，
没有那么快，
但是福利几句增加，
劳动时间几句所短的状态，
8小时工作制就是在区间内主建的晚膳，
然后劳工的福利也是在区间内主建的晚膳，
结果好了到了80年代，
又一轮工业革命来了，
就是信息革命，
半导体，
互联网，
计算机主导了这样的技术进步，
然后劳动强度在很多地方再次回升，
又上伤得很大，
然后最近一些年，
就是从2015年到现在，
中国的人均工作时长登场了一个月，
我觉得上次你给我提过这个数据，
我也觉得中国的劳动者真的太伟大了，
就是相当于多了20个工作日，
对,
所以整个来说我们看到的技术的进步，
和劳动时间的强度反成了一个证比，
就是你技术越强，
反而劳动的强度更大，
按道理不应该是技术越强，
工作就越轻松嘛，
对啊,
一开始说机器可以替代人干那些危险，
或者很枯燥的工作，
结果人的工作时长反而更长了，
而且我感觉这个势头似乎在AI时代，
也有重现的趋势，
大家都觉得以为AI可以替你做很多事情，
但事实上其实大家变得更卷了，
这就是一个非常有意思的情况，
前段时间有一篇文章很火，
就说AI来了之后会代替很多工作，
很多人失业或者担心失业，
然后最终导致消费趋势的保守，
然后最终导致全社会的大的同缩，
使经历崩溃，
有一个这样的推演，
我就觉得蛮有意思的，
这是一个非常乐观的推演，
就是你会觉得，
大规模失业是个乐观的推演嘛，
对，你会觉得你会没事儿干，
这个在我看来是不太可能的，
就是你会有更多的事儿干，
你会更忙，
整件事情会分成两个阶段，
第一个阶段叫社会总需求，
尚未满足的阶段，
在这个阶段你会以为AI来了之后，
大家人被代替或者人的工作强度，
小姐其实不是的，
因为老板的欲望会上升，
就是你原本在笔记本时代，
手写的时代你说你五千字的文章，
你需要三天把它写好认识好，
老板觉得还行，
等到集团机来了，
然后你可以打字了，
可以有编辑工具了，
老板就说你两天就太久了，
你就一天就做完，
现在有AI了，
他就要求你一天要做三篇，
然后他的整体的强度是不会下降的，
他会随着生产力的进步，
你的工作目标会增长，
而且这里还有一个更低于的事情就是，
随着生产力的进步技术的提高，
其实对于劳动的这种监管的手段是加强的，
比如你以前你在纸笔时代，
你想摸个鱼，
很难有人去发现，
你一天少工作两个小时，
对吧，偷偷的发发呆，
喝喝茶，
再间歇的休息一下，
这个不太有人管你，
然后到了互联网时代，
其实这种监测工具就已经逐渐的要了出行，
有一些工作软件，
时不时的在一些不应该出现的时间，
打扰你的生活，
盯你一下，
但接下来在AI时代，
这个事情一定会被老板用起来的，
就是让AI监视你的工作，
啊，太低音了，
就大家可能还没有想到这一层，
大家只想的是AI代替我工作，
但AI可以监视你工作，
比如说你偷懒了五分钟，
AI会告诉你，
你不要再偷懒了，
你要开始好好工作，
你再偷懒我就跟老板说了，
那这和以前的血汗工厂有什么区别呢？
所以大家误以为，
劳动的时间，
劳动的机会是跟
生产力的工具相关的，
不是的，
你的劳动的机会和劳动的强度，
只跟生产关系相关，
就是在总需求上面完成的阶段，
你能不能有充足的休息和好的员工福利，
只取决于这种有没有人足够多的人代替你，
然后只取决于老板有没有动机去改革生产制度？
OK,
但我觉得这些可能大家听起来还是有点疏灭，
啊，我这样说吧，
就是我们的八小时工作制，
不是因为生产力进步而获得的天然的福利，
是因为当时有一些地方在进行叫无产阶阶革命，
我们这些伟大的先驱闻，
对无产阶级的革命的先驱闻，
由于他们的存在，
所以资本主义社会不得不让步，
当时大家可能不知道这个，
在苏联最强盛的时候，
西方的很多国家，
包括欧洲当时这种资本家的所得税，
所有的税制累积起来可以干到80%-90%，
就是你挣100块钱，
你要交80-90块钱给国家，
为什么呢？
因为如果你不交的话，
这些工人起来把这个桌子一掀，
你不但所有的资产都没了，
而且命可能都没了，
所以为了阻止这件事情发生，
当时的资本主义的统治群体，
决定这种重税对他们自己是一种保护，
你交了80-90日后，
工人运动就不会那么积极，
交了这个重税，
他也会以某种福利的方式发放给这些工人，
对，而且工作时间，
这个工作强度，
还有这种工作关系都得到了非常好的改善，
这是当年在冷战时期，
当时很多西方的科学家，
政治人士，
很多其实内心是认可这种无产阶级的理念的，
共产主义的理念的，
所以西方阵营就很低防这件事情，
对，如果你天天工作很累，
如果你的工资福利不好，
然后资本家还过得很逍遥，
工人运动就很容易陷起来，
但资本家现在说，
我交80-90%的税，
然后你们每天只干八个小时，
你看你万一把我推翻了，
你也就是这个生活嘛，
大家就不要那么较真儿了，
或者说这样的话，
他的革命的成本就会变高，
我要呼吁更多的人，
别人说现在这资本家已经蛮惨的了，
革命前后我都是八小时，
我这个就没有这个态度动力，
所以它是一种妥协，
就是当时的资本主义社会对于劳工一种妥协，
不是生产力带来的变革，
对，它不是技术进步带来的，
它不是技术进步，
技术进步会带来更高的生产的要求，
更长的劳动时间，
这种工业化的管理，
其实随着生产的进步是越来越容易的，
你每天工作多长时间，
然后你有没有在发呆，
这东西以后，
其实这一套已经用在很多学校里面了呀，
监控孩子有没有打瞌睡啊，
有没有走神，
我在短视频上已经刷了一些家长在家，
给那个小学生做作业的时候，
放一个豆包在旁边，
他如果在，
比如说墨相匹啊，
或者在走神的时候，
豆包就说，
你是不是有提不会啦，
这个不要走神啊，
类似这样，
现在很得意说这个豆包真是个好帮手，
以前都要我盯着孩子写作业，
现在豆包可以帮我盯着孩子写作业了，
但是我们其实心里想的是，
那你上班的时候，
如果有个人这样盯着你怎么办，
然后这实地上一定会发生，
哎呀我这个还毛直述，
就是好消息，
其实大家不用太担心被AIT带失业的问题，
是坏消息是，
你到时候可能会想说我还不如失业，
对AI会变成一个监工，
可能不是一个摄像头或者一个什么，
它会是一种比较全面的一个形式，
更好的考察你的工作，
这个事情现在，
实际上一定有很多工作在做了，
因为在中国的AI的逻辑是先从B段开始，
美国的AI的技术营业王是先从C段开始，
现在普通用户开始用起来，
中国更务实一点，
因为现在你要让用户掏很多钱去买AI服务，
不太容易，
同时有很多的大厂它是在免费提供服务，
所以你在收钱就更难，
但是B段它是愿意付费的，
因为它有直接的生产效益，
比如说现在面试，
AI作为一个面试官来说，
它比很多基础的H2已经好很多了，
其实这个我觉得它倒是一个，
就是整体评估来讲这个反而是一个好事儿，
我觉得对于面试者来说，
你不太会受到面试官的个人喜好或者心情影响，
对,
所以这是一种心目，
就是说企业会偏向于先为它付费，
其中就有一个重要的部分叫做提升劳动效率，
怎么提升呢？
首先要分析你的劳动效率吧，
分析劳动效率这就是AI很重要的一个应用，
比如说同样的岗位，
ABCD它们分别的做得怎么样，
然后以前那是一个相对主观的东西，
然后AI它就可以帮你更好的量化，
更好的拆分，
更好的去管理你，
那一旦这样量化之后，
其实很多事情是经不住量化的，
上伯班的朋友都明白，
对吧?
对,
这真的是经不住量化的，
而且随时AI它如果接入了，
其实现在已经在发生了各种的办公软件，
比如说你开场会，
AI会最后会给你一个总结，
谁在这个会议中表现比较突出，
谁的贡献比较多，
但相应的谁的贡献比较少，
那么时间长了，
它其实AI就可以给你做击销分析，
没错,
以后一定是这个趋势，
而且它会先于AI在生活中的普通应用，
B端一定是先看着用的，
因为B端有人付费，
那到时候我们的劳动会异化成什么样子，
我甚至觉得，
易飞老师你前面说的可能还有点乐观，
就是你只是想摸鱼，
摸不了，
因为有一个AI监工，
但很可能到那个时候，
你的工作内容也都是AI给你指派的，
你只是在执行AI的一些命令，
或者这样说吧，
就是大家都用AI工具，
对,
你用AI工具提升你的生产效率，
你的老板也用，
就像农业时代，
大家都在种田，
在没有好的出头的时候呢，
有些田你就不用去种了，
因为你种完，
你会发现你投入的人力和肥料，
是收不回来这个成本的，
地主只会让你去耕那些良田，
所以这样的话，
其实你的工作量是没那么高的，
但是由于有了好的工具，
好的礼仪，
然后可以开腾更多的荒地，
所以你的劳动强度变大了，
以前我会比如说一件事情，
需要20个人的存队来做，
那我老板就要考虑考虑成本，
但现在，
一个人带一些便宜的AI工具他就可以做，
老板马上就想这个事原来可以做，
然后他也可以挣钱，
这个费销笔下就算过来了，
然后你就要去做那些原本20个人去做的事情，
你带着你的AI小伙伴们，
一个人去做原本20个人要做的事情，
对,
因为以前这个账是算不过来的，
现在能算过来你就得要去做了，
然后现在实际上就是，
你现在的工作量是，
看起来这样，
等到AI进步之后，
你的工作量可能会翻3倍、5倍、10倍，
你的生产能力也是3倍、5倍、10倍，
然后最终又会产生一个新的匹配，
我觉得我们刚才聊天有点把老板，
塑造成了一个万恶的反派，
可是如果真的老板的角度他也会觉得说，
那可能之前我的公司只能在，
假设在鱼行，
只能做这一片的业务，
但是随着技术的发展，
我发现我可以做全杭州了，
我可以做全浙江了，
包括他也会想到如果我不做，
那我的金融对手他也会做，
这个总是没有好坏，
这是一种社会规律，
就是谁上谁都这样，
因为如果你不这样做的话你就消失了，
就是为了生存，
对啊,
因为别人的员工都一个人干以前五个人的活，
大家的生产力，
大家都带上了更强的工具之后，
你说你的员工仍然干一些一个人的活，
成本就会很高，
然后你就会被这个市场淘汰，
我知道这个天下很天真啊，
就是为什么大家不能集体降半一下脚步，
就像我观测到的2025年的欧洲一样，
这就需要一个更高的高于市场的一种调节的力量，
就是因为在社交媒体上，
大家现在提到欧洲，
都是说你看这个德国也落后了，
法国也不行，怎么怎么样，
很多人是不屑于他们那种打引好的杨朗翰的行为的，
以及他们的这种低效率，
可是我们当然也不是说我们要追求像他们一样，
而是说我们能不能取一个平衡，
而不是一直在疯狂的不停的往前卷，
就是前几天德国总理不是来了中国吗，
然后来了杭州，
看完之后他回去之后就发表了一个演讲，
说我们每周工到四天是不行的，
work life balance是不行的,。
这个就是刚才我们说的，
你可以这样做，
但你最终会被淘汰，
然后你的产业就会被蚕食，
原本可以维系的这个状态是维系不了的，
这个就是运转的规律，
但你换个角度想，
就是先前后苦还是先苦后甜，
而且先苦后甜，
这个后甜以我们过往的经验，
你也不知道什么时候能来，
我是非常赞同生活和工作平衡的，
我们公司你可能知道，
首先我自己带头，
强度很低，
然后我们公司基本上很少有人加班，
我们周六日都是放假，
然后像我们法宁假日，
我一般还会稍微多给一点，
所以这个是我们企业的企业文化，
但是你这个就面临的一个情况，
就是你必须有非常好的战略方向和非常好的生涯模式，
用来弥补，
对，你要有独特竞争优势，
没错,
你要弥补这些成本，
我愿意支付这些成本，
包括我们年中奖什么的给的还算大方，
就是因为你必须要有非常好的生涯模式，
这些东西其实是很高的要求，
然后你要维持这些情况，
不是每个公司有这样的幸运，
对,
这个也不一定是老板的能力高低吧，
他有的时候就是，
你选择的行业可能就决定了，
对对对，
虽然我这样做，
但是我理解你先让员工求救流的企业，
我们那天专门减的算了一个账，
就一个员工，
如果他工资是两万块钱，
然后他每天工作八个小时，
然后双修，
那么他一个月的工作时间是174个小时，
如果活太多做不完，
我再找一个人，
那两个人的成本就是四万块钱，
现在我们加上社保，
两个人的工资之外，
再加上社保就是五万七，
这个是两个人的工作成本，
这个时候呢，
他的工作时间是174个小时乘以二，
大概三百多个小时，
那如果我让一个人九九六，
他一个月也能干三百多个小时，
我给他双倍的加班费，
加班的时间给他乘以二，
那就是七千三百块钱，
再加他一个人的社保，
总成本也只有三万五，
那么一下子我就省掉了两万多块钱，
而且我十小招一个人之后，
我可以省下招聘培训福利，
公务位这些成本，
然后如果我免满二十个员工干这个活儿，
现在我只有十个人加班就能干完，
我基层员工少了，
我是不是经理也能减少，
管理层也能减少，
总监也能减少，
管理层的工资是一个很重的开销，
那这样直接就肯定把人家务事，
人家降低了很多沟通上的摩擦，
对,
所以一个正常的老板啊，
如果按经营效率来算的话，
我是宁可给双倍的加班费，
让现有的团队去加班，
我也不想找训员工，
这个账是一个非常经济的账，
你这样突然起发了，
我就是很多大厂，
他会给员工提供十点之后打车报销的答应号的福利，
其实也是一个经济证，
所有的账，
就是未来啊，
你像这个大厂，
比如说搞AI的，
搞这种机器学习的这些最热门的方向的优秀的员工，
我觉得他们未来一定会配全套的生活服务，
什么司机、保姆这些东西应该都要配上，
这个账才算得过来，
因为我让这个人每天一个小时的时间在他的生活上面，
他的大脑不管他去休息还是投入到工作里面，
给公司带来的手艺都远远高于司机加保姆这些成本，
但这不也是在把人彻底的工具化吗？
那你要说确实是这样，
因为不把人彻底工具化的企业是竞争不过的，
就是竞争不过那些把人工具化的企业，
这就是技术进步，
且不加过多干预，
会带来自然结果？
自然结果，
所以你一定要有一些制度上面的变革才能阻止这些事情发生。
除了效率以外，
追求一些其他东西，
比如说居民生活水平、
居民幸福度的这样的考核的一个政府，
或者一个能够对抗这种制度的团体。
这些东西是阻止这些发生的力量，
还是那句话，
这里没有坏人。
真的吗？
除了那些说变态老板，
就是你明明没什么事为了，
让你不帮公司做着，
这个就是有病了，
我是特别不理解这些人的，
因为你让员工在这里做着也好，
让员工提供情绪价值也好，
这些东西都是很贵的。
我们把人分成三类，
一类是他既有能力，
情商又很高，
就是很好的给老板提供情绪价值这些人。
一类是他有能力，
但是不愿意给老板提供情绪价值。
但是他工作效率很高，
一类他既没能力，
但是又愿意给老板提供情绪价值。
这里实际上，
这个情绪价值就是一个很贵的成本，
你要选第一种又有情商又有智商的超级员工。
那也很贵。
他很贵，
因为会有很多老板想要他，
然后你就需要去跟马云，
需要去跟这些顶级的富豪去抢别人，
你抢不到的。
接下来你就二选一，
你要么就是他很聪明，
要么就是他愿意去支付这种情绪劳动，
那我是你，
因为他聪明一点，
他不要有太多情绪劳动，
消耗在我这里。
正常人其实是，
我都要，
我会强迫有能力的人，
你必须给我提供情绪价值。
那他就会去找一个开价更高的老板啊？
对嘛,
他在我这服务一天，
我就要逼他干这个事情。
那你当然可以这样做，
但是最终这个效率是不高的，
还是那句话，
这也是一个市场最终的导向。
这所有东西都是供需决定的。
可是我刚才在想说，
我们会不会讨论的还是太乐观了，
就是我们如此斩定解铁的说，
AI他并不会导致大规模的失业，
我觉得这个事情还是会的，
以及它正在发生啊。
结构性失业肯定会，
就是有一句话叫，
如果你今天一个人失业了，
你今天晚上是睡不着觉的。
但是如果有一亿人同时失业了，
你就放心的睡。
就是你欠银行十万和欠银行一个亿的区别。
对，就是有人会来替你解决的。
所以我觉得失业这块呢，
我真的不是很担心，
因为就是咱们中国在这个领域是全球最有经验的国家。
因为我觉得在中国呢，
其实角色层肯定是有相关的考虑的，
而且我们实际上已经经历过很多次了，
这个东西叫做产业积聚。
国外呢，刚才说的那个是，
AI出来之后有一些地方的人叫无效人口了。
无效人口就是它既没有生产力，
它的生产力比不为AI，
也没有消费力，
因为它没有收入了。
那这部分的GDP啊，
这部分的这个经济运转也好，
就从整个总量里面消失了，
所以这个对经济是一个冲击对吧。
因为你的整个经济体变小之后，
哪怕是上层的人呢，
它的市场也变小了，
劳动力供给也变小了，
相当于按比例来说，
它也会受影响，
但在中国这个情况是这样的，
我们有大量的地区，
早就已经经历过这样的情况，
点名东北西北中部的一些资源城市，
或者曾经的工业基地，
然后被被迫去工业化之后，
然后人口人才资本外流之后，
这些地方实际上逐渐雕壁枯尾，
没有产业，
然后我们的做法是，
通过财政转移支付的财政开销，
也就是叫两个出口，
一个是饭体之内的，
包括公务员，
事业边国企这些单位的工资，
然后养老金，
然后这是一个出口，
另外一个出口就是当地的。
成建基建的财政支出的项目，
搞一些建设呀，
开大阑上的大哥们，
对吧,
拿一些项目回来分包分包，
绿化绿化，
钱就到包工头手里，
最终到劳工手里，
这两条出口，
就形成了当地唯一的两个活钱的来源，
有很多地区线就是这样的，
比如乡镇，
所以就会有大家在网上热议的。
现成普罗门的这个现象，
对，现成普罗门，
然后这个现成其实是没有产业的，
这个现成所有的产业，
就是公务员的工资和政府的项目，
那些地区极端一点的说，
是所有的人都在吃这两口活水，
你去开餐饮的也是，
餐饮店的服务员本身也是，
因为新增的社会价值，
新增的社会资源，
只来源于那两个出口，
所以你即使是开餐饮的，
你也是服务于这些公务员，
然后国企的人，
赚的本质还是那个钱，
只是他过了几刀手，
所以你说了普罗门，
实际上是离水管更近的人，
但是所有人其实都在喝这个水龙头流出来的水，
只是有些人离得近一点，
他多喝了一点，
有的人离得远他少喝了一点，
但是这个地方的水源只有这两个水龙头，
OK,
这个事情对于，
其实很多城市的人，
并不是一个很新鲜的事儿，
对于很多地方，
就是已经现在去当下，
或者已经过了很多年了，
都没了一些领厂，
原先的矿业城市、资源城市，
然后一些三线建设城市，
在新时代之后的改革之后的一些地区，
都面临一样的情况。
所以站在像你这样的，
经济学研究者的角度，
会不会觉得有点奇怪，
为什么大家现在这么担心，
因为AI失业，
因为本质上可能，
其实有相当多一部分的人，
他本来赚的就不是这个钱。
对,
就是实际上我们只是把这部分人口和地区，
进一步扩大。
对，可以这样理解。
对。
就当生产力进步，
随着技术的发展，
生产力进步，
它势必导致产业急剧，
以至于有一些地区、地方，
它可能就会成为，
像我们前面说的矿场临厂这样的情况。
生活在这些地区的人的生活，
怎么存序，
怎么让大家过上更好的生活。
我们很有经验。
对，我们已经其实已经有了经验。
那其实考验的就是，
这个技术发展，
能不能给国家带来足够多的GDP的增量？
对,
所以从经济学的角度讲，
生产力进步带来的危机永远是短暂，
而且必要的。
就是生产力的进步这件事情，
从经济学底层逻辑来讲，
它永远是一个好的东西。
有时候跟你们这些搞经济学的人聊天吧，
就觉得很残酷。
就是我们这个发展曲线上面是一条鞋线往上，
中间会有很多波浪，
波浪是叫周期性的产业调整也好，
就业的变化也好，
社会应对生产力进步的冲击的适应的阶段也好，
政策可以叫消风填骨，
消风填骨来减缓波动率，
但是这条向上的曲线，向上的趋势是不变的。
只要生产力进步，
人类能够创造的价值，
创造的财富的总量是上升的，
那么最终人均分下的财富的总量也是更多的。
只是一波浪总会让很多人跌落。
对，就是总量上升之后，
就是分配机制嘛。
对，那些当中受益的人能不能愿意分出来一部分，
使得那些没有受益的人也能够分享到一些发展的红利。
这个就是刚才说的那些地区的人口。
嗯，你如果按纯粹的市场经济的角度讲，
那按西方的讲法就是无效人口。
哎，你们怎么会发明无效人口这么惨过的词？
这不是我发明的这个，
对，你们这些人，
从经济角度讲他们对经济来说，
当然他们作为人当然是平等的，
但是从你把经济当做一个单独的。
玻璃于社会以外的一个实体来看，
就是相对而言就是，
对，我现在感觉很像是吃鸡游戏里面那个缩圈，
缩圈对不对？
对，就是这个圈越缩越小，
而不是说圈外就活不了，
只是说圈外它是另外一个游戏玩法。
你说的实际上这个东西叫做双轨制的发展的情况，
现在在全球特别是中美，
有特别明显的这样的趋势，
就是与AI和新侵产力相关的那一波人，
与它无关的一波人，
如果我更极端一点讲叫与马斯克相关的人和与马斯克无关的人，
那你这是有点极端，
对，就是你看现在整个资本市场炒的概念也是，
无论是商业航天，AI，机器人，
这个自动驾驶叫马斯克相关概念和马斯克无关概念，
就所谓的那些老灯资产就是传统产业，
怎么说定价是完全不一样的逻辑，
然后这里还有一点有趣就是，
其实我们中国现在还没有那么明显的感觉，
但是美国那边在硅谷相关的区域和非硅谷相关的区域的，
因为通胀的水平大概是共享的，
两边其实工资收入的当然都在上涨，
但上涨的比例是完全不一样的，
就是一个能够找到AI相关的工作的毕业生，
他拿到的工资可能是一个与之无关的传统产业这些，
工资好多倍，
增速也完全不一样，
这个一个世界国内还没有那么明显，
就是你如果去一趟美国你就会明显的感觉，
他的消费的水平，
包括给小费的比例，
就像两个用完全不一样货币的国家一样，
中国现在还没有这么明显，
但是以后也慢慢，
就是说方式可能没有这么明显，
但是在新筹待遇上其实已经就是一个红钩，
你是一个顶尖院校AI方向的硬接生，
那你的工资就是几百万人民币起，
是，现在就是叫双轨制嘛，
一边是大量的毕业生挨好找不到工作，
另一边是就那几十个人被狂抢，
他们沐浴在神圣的时代的进步的光泽当中，
不但赚了很多钱，
同时还背负着带领人类往前走的这样神圣的使命。
哦，如果考虑到后半句的话，
好像就是大家的仇富心里会淡一点。
哦，他们不光赚很多钱，
而且他们精神上面还很爽。
你看这就是表白意识，
但你说他们精神上面还很爽的时候，
这就让人喉嚨爽了。
啊，所以就是，
现在这发展就有点双轨制的趋势。
你这个双轨制跟大家传统印象中的双轨制，
都不是一个概念。
经济发展的双轨制会比较双速区间，
就是两个空间好像的速率已经完全不一样了。
工作的速率，增长的速率，
面对未来的这种兴奋的感受，是完全不一样的。
这个让我想到昨天跟男士陆伯克的时候，
他说了一句话我印象还很深，
他说就像今年的春晚，
大家看到这个什么机器人啊，
自动驾驶啊，以及新能源啊，
就是这些产业蓬勃向上，
看着很开心，
但是一看自己家庭的资产负债表，
都是钢筋、水泥，
这些所谓的传统老灯资产，
跟春晚、新相罗那些没有任何的关系。
是，就是会有一种被抛弃的感觉。
对,
而且现在的年轻人其实面临到一个新的情况，
不知道你有没有感觉，
就是这是一个大政委时代，
就是很多东西都被政委了，
比如说你看一下吧，
我立即会有回报嘛。
不光是这些，就是网上很多拍断的说这个亲情啊，
这些亲戚啊，
就是过年回家，
好像也怕你穷，
也见不得你富。
对,
怕你过得苦，
也怕你开了火。
然后呢，
爱情呢，
现在这个男女的关系，
性别的这种冲突又很激烈，
然后大家也觉得爱情是不是，
或者说我会不会足够幸运，
遇到一段爱情，
这个东西也被政委。
就以前大家都是很期待这个事情啊，
现在就充满了戒备和地方，
对吧,
在爱情当中。
然后这种理想主义，
说我必然会成为一个，
社会有用的分子，
或者说我必然会过好我的一生，
这种信念，
有的时候现在很多人也在动摇，
就是他也不知道这个时代，
到底自己还能够参与什么，
包括你刚才说的这种，
努力必然会或者回报的，
这种正反馈机制。
很多我们以前，
叫战略性的共识，
现在逐渐都在消解，
对,
然后消解完了之后，
年轻人会觉得，
那到底什么是真的呢？
包括资产也是，
你刚才说的，
这个房子，
以前就觉得非常稳定的资产，
一直这样，
肯定是有足够信仰的，
这个东西也在瓦解。
就是给我的感受是，
尤其是年轻人，
仿佛有一种整体的，
就是那种犯抑郁状态，
就是没有活力，
觉得很多事情都没什么意思。
迷茫,
我觉得是一种，
对,
一方面迷茫，
一方面觉得很多事情没什么意思，
平时能够获取到很多信息，
因为那些都是拓手可得的，
但是,
其实并不知道自己真正想要什么，
想追求什么，
也不知道自己该做什么。
就是信息多了，
和选择多了这件事情，
我觉得不一定是点好事情，
人一旦选择多了，
你会面临一个情况，
工作的时候，
你天天就可以骂老板，
如果你突然有一天，
可以不用工作，
你就需要对你人生活中的，
所有的问题，
付选择，
你的所有的选择，
比如你可以选择出去旅游，
可以选择去努力，
做好一项这个爱好，
但是你都没有选，
这个时候所有的压力都在你自己身上，
就是人类，
如果你有充分的，
完全的自主的选择之后，
这个重量是很重的，
就像创业，
这是一个很重重量的东西，
你谁也怪不了，
干砸了全是你的问题，
当你有100%的自由的时候，
就意味着你要承担100%的后果，
所以这选择太多，
我不知道是不是一个，
能够更让人幸福的事情。
那如果按照这个逻辑的话，
以后有我AI监工，
反而是可以怪AI，
听起来似乎也并不一定是一件坏事。
我有的时候觉得人类有的时候是喜欢被指导的，
有的时候是喜欢，
有人告诉你你要干什么的。
所以现在玄学大型祈祷啊，
大家希望自己当时出生的那一年，
那个月那个日那个时间的星辰，
或者是那八个字能告诉自己，
自己的未来的这个人生的听话版是什么，
自己是个什么样的行业，
具体到这一年我的孕是什么样的，
这个月是什么样的，
然后我怎么责业，怎么理财，怎么做。
对，人是喜欢有这样的确定性，
有这样的建议的，有这样的指导的。
虽然这样听起来很不自由，
但是这个其实跟幸福感的关联是很强的。
我有的时候去大学演讲，
或者就是参加大学的活动，
看到大学里面那些着急蓬勃的年轻人，
我就会很羡慕。
你现在还着急蓬勃吗？
我不在，我不着急蓬勃了，
我看到他们我会觉得自己很卑劣，
就是你会觉得他们有无限的可能，
然后你会愿意去为这种可能性支付很多东西，
然后你知道人类的越年轻的时候，
你的选择可能是越多的。
随着你年纪变大，
你的选择是不断收窄的。
比如说我现在就不可能辞职去当一个医生，
或者一个律师，或者一个化学教练，
这已经不在我人生的选项内了，
但20岁的人他就可以。
所以他们非常的焦虑和迷茫。
对，然后我的人生未来会越来越窄，
收出的可能性就越来越少，
然后到我死前的那一刻就只剩一条线了，
就我所有的平均宇宙都收在那一条线上，
然后你再往回看，
你就发现人生其实只有一个选择，
就是我一方面很羡慕这个年轻人的这种无限可能性，
无限的机会，无限的，
就我在他们面前显得自己的卑劣，
是因为他们很天真，
他们没有我们内心的这么多认知，
或者所谓认知，或者算计，或者这种很苟且的东西，
但是你一方面就觉得确实这带来的是很大的压力，
我现在没有选择也意味着我不需要再去想那些东西，
人是不会为自己做不到的是你焦虑的，
你会焦虑是因为我还有可能性，
我没有尽力，
如果我尽力了，
我说不定可以做得更好，
这时候你会焦虑，
比如说我现在不会焦虑我能不能跑得过波尔特，
我永远不会为这件事你焦虑对吧，
因为我知道我永远不可能，
你也不会为你没有马斯克有钱而傲能，
对啊,
但是比如说我现在可能会焦虑，
我下一条内容能不能做得更好，
然后我会焦虑我明年的增长能不能保持我现在增速，
嗯,
就这些东西我会焦虑，
因为我做得到，
只要我努力就能做得到，
那这些东西其实是不一定是件好事，
因为现在信息兔手可得，
所以对于当下的年轻人他其实知道，
现在这个时光很宝贵，
他确实有很多的可能性，
但是并没有人真的能够基于他的情况，
他的家庭条件他的成长背景他的受教育经历，
来帮他制定一个这样的规划，
所以很容易陷入这样的迷茫和焦虑当中，
没错,
就是接受这个时代的愧憎，
同时也意味着你要接受无限的挑战，
那我们这些终老登到了这个阶段了，
你其实心情已经很松弛了，
因为这，
你反正很多时间也选不了，
因为我们已经错过了，
对,
我们已经错过了，
就是,
你错过啥了，
时代红利哪一波你没吃上，
不不不，
就AI这个我已经可能确信自己不会是，
AI时代的重要参与者，
实际上，
因为AI到现在中国这边差不多是一年时间嘛，
很多的，
我看很多的朋友圈里有人在不断的学习新的技术，
会给你带来焦虑吗？
对,
我其实可以跟朋友们说一声，
就是我的体验是，
你现在什么也不学，
然后如果哪天你突然想学了，
你学一个礼拜，
然后你掌握的先进的这些AI的工具，
实际上跟那些一直在学的人是一样，
就这个东西现在的由于他的，
更新,
变态速度太快了，
所以个人的积累是非常不是很有效率的，
嗯,
然后你需要等他到了某一个大半本，
到了一个阶段性的东西，
然后你稍微学明白一点，
但是真的到了那个大半本，
他之所以能成为大半本，
就是因为他的学习们看会非常低，
对,
然后会非常多的人掌握，
如果一个东西只有极少数人掌握，
但他有效率非常好的话，
就一定会有其他人出来做一个东西，
把它简化到大家都能用，
嗯,
所以我就这一点上面，
我常常做安慰，
就是你看朋友圈里很热闹的人，
今天爆炸式的一个，
几乎每天都有爆炸性的新工具，
对对对，
一个改变时代的一个新的什么东西出来了，
我们时代每天都被刷新，
哎，没错，
然后但是实际上呢，
过了一个月可能又新的改变又出来了，
就上一个被改变的时代又改变，
所以你就不着急学吧，
静观其变，
就是学习和掌握AI工具，
帮自己提升效率这件事情肯定是好的，
但是我觉得易飞老师说，
没有必要那么焦虑，
把时间全花在研究AI，
专业AI而忽略了自己的本职工作，
这个可能就会有点得不偿失，
因为就像易飞老师说的，
之后AI肯定会有一个大版本的迭代器，
让绝大部分人都可以学习使用，
他的门槛会很低，
那个时候考验的其实就是你在别的领域的积累，
怎么样迭加上这个AI的应用的技术。
是，最终我们在AI时代能够保留现在的东西，
实际上是我们现实生活的体验和，
就所谓的灵魂嘛。
你到底在AI时代你逼别人抢在哪里，
不是抢在你的对AI的更熟悉或者AI工具使用更强，
而是你有更多的主观的生命体验，
然后能够与AI更好地去结合，
我觉得这个可能是一个更重要的方向嘛。
我觉得再回到最开始和易飞老师聊的这个话题，
当时旅游回来让我陷入深深思考的是，
就是为什么感觉我们就永远没有办法休息，
前面我们在聊的是比如说我举中午吃完卖的这个例子，
我们疲惫到我没有办法吃一顿好好的饭，
以至于从中诞生了一个可能几百亿或者更大市值的这样的一个行业，
就是休息这个事情仿佛，
在我们这些就是没有合法性。
再比如说，我也跟易飞老师讲过，
就是我最近几个月很爱看永哥说餐饮嘛，
就是觉得很奇怪，
很多人把自己一生的积蓄，
甚至上杠杆，
几十万，
大几十万，
杂下去去开一个可能根本不可能赚钱的店，
仿佛大家没有办法接受自己只是休息一段时间，
总觉得自己得干点什么，得做点什么。
你说的那个餐饮的那件事情，
我们先拆开说，
就是我觉得这是一个社会财富再分配的，
就我们都说你挣不到认知意外的钱，
或者你运气赚的钱靠实力会还回去，
这就是一种还回去的方式方法，
然后这些钱会留到那些，
比如说家门方，
或者材料方，
或者供应商的手里，
然后进行社会的再分配，
所以我一直说，
这个我们要鼓励富二代创业，
我们应该更多的设立一些富二代的创业偶像，
就是因为一个事情你一定要让它显得光荣，
大家才会受到感招嘛，
就像你武艺劳动奖章，
劳动最光荣，
然后给这些老摩去颁奖，
然后大家就知道劳动是一个光荣的事情，
但是在现在这个叫我们反内卷也好，
某种意义上的逆通障，
这个词我们谨慎一点，
逆通障的情况之下，
我们是不是应该给社会树立一些新的榜样，
就这些比如说富二代的创业者，
就是投入很大的钱去消费的这些人，
弄一个比如双十一消费奖章，
富二代创业奖章，
我觉得你这个对于中国社会还是来说还是太超钱了，
肯定当然不会真的这样做，
我只说这个倾向上面，
我们是不是稍微可以倾向一点，
讲一些富二代创业故事，
因为有钱人如果只是很简朴的生活的话，
他永远会有钱下去的，
就应该让他们猛猛炫富，
对猛猛炫富让猛猛创业，
创造更多的岗位，
对创造更多的岗位让最终亏的钱是他的嘛，
因为所谓的亏掉的钱，
这个钱不是无端消失的，
他会有人去挣到这个钱的，
一个人的消费就另外一个人收入嘛，
所以我要让这些资本转起来，
在某种程度上是需要这样的，
或者说这些钱最终会留到更有资格拥有他们的人手里，
或者钱在一些效率更高的地方，
对这个社会价值更大。
我觉得你们这些分析问题真的从来不关心个人生活，
都是站在整体效用最大的角度。
是，因为比如同样是100万，
如果一个富二代他拿去银行里存着，
当然这个贷款最终会通过银行带给那些需要贷款的企业，
这也是一个方式。
但是呢，他如果拿去快速的把他给创业了，
这么听起来怎么创业，像是一个动词啊，
快速的把他创业了，
这样这些钱就会流入到这个带来手里，
这是一个我觉得比较好的情形。
但是我觉得我举的那些例子，
他们基本都是普通老百姓，
他跟富二代没有关系，
大部分跟富二代没有关系，
甚至跟技术进步没有关系，
就是感觉这个社会不允许你好好的休息。
就是儒家的文化，
叠加这个高的经济增长速率，
你有没有看到就是二战之后到现在，
新兴的发展，
增速高的发达国家达经济体，
全都是这个儒家文化圈。
美国不是啊？
美国是二战之前就富的呀。
哦,OK。
对，就是新富起来的这一波，
就这些儒家文化圈辐射到的地方就特别适配，
现在的这个生产力和生产关系，
然后一有机会呢，
就会迅速的膨胀起来，
但是这头巨兽呢，
到某个阶段他又会，
就是引发各种各样的社会问题，
就是我们到底卷到哪里？
就是现在就是你刚才说那一点，
就是我们增长的目标到底是什么？
对呀。
我们增长的目标是为了更多的增长，
还是为了，
给人感觉就是为了更多的增长。
这个就是一直没有得到很好解释的事情。
对呀，就是大家努力工作，
不是为了更好的生活吗？
为什么感觉大家努力的工作，
就是为了能拥有更努力工作的机会呢？
在上一个叙事当中，
我们努力工作坚苦奋斗，
是为了实现共产主义的伟大理想。
但是当下我们在有一新的考量，
就是这个叙事似乎有点遥远，
跟我当下的生活有什么关系？
这种迷茫是可以有的，
因为你只有提出这些问题，
我们才有很好的回答。
最终会有一代人实现这点事情。
就像刚才我们说的，
AI的两个阶段，
第一个阶段叫总需求尚未满足的阶段，
会利用这种工具，
你会有更高的工作目标，
更多的工作量。
第二个阶段就是总需求得到了成分满足，
就是每个人都可以得到自己想要的东西，
你想要什么东西马上就有的时候，
这个就是一个新的阶段，
那那个时候是不是就不用那么完美的工作了。
但是那个阶段好像跟我们这一代人又离得比较远。
我是在想说，
就是随着技术的发展，
然后呢我们能创造如此多的物质价值，
是不是又有一个时间点，
我们是可以停下来的。
那你说生产力或者社会发展的节点呢，
现在我们中国实际上就在重新思考这件事情，
就是我们在民生开支，
在整个社会当中比众，
我们现在在提升，
包括从去年开始我们叫提升消费。
这里其实就在解答一个问题，
我们的发展到底是为了什么？
发展是为了更多的发展，
还是发展是为了人去更好的生活。
之前我们不顾一切的往前走，
是因为还没有资格去更深刻的想这个事情。
那现在呢，
实际上从24年下半年开始，
绝对从意识到了这一点，
并且做出了对应的策略，
不论是发消费券，
还是生意补贴，
还是更多的这种民生向的开支，
包括今年我们一定会看到更多的对消费的提振，
都是在试图解决，
或者某种意义上的去改善缓解这个问题。
可能更多人会以为只是为了提振经济而已。
这一举两得，
这是一个问题的两面，
就是因为我们发展到了生产力充沛的阶段，
所以我们才有资格来想这个问题。
那同时也是因为我们生产力发展到了充沛的阶段，
所以我们就要面临说，
供需不平衡，需求不足的问题。
所以这是生产力发展到供给足够充沛之后，
我们才有资格思考的东西。
因为在中国历史上的大部分时间是生产力不足，
消费过剩。
所以我们一直在讲坚固奋斗，
在提倡解减，
这是一种文化惯性。
终于到了这个阶段，
2023、2024年开始,。
中国出现了产能过剩。
然后这个东西才会我们第一次松绑说，
有一天造的东西实在是太多了，
实在是消化不了了，
我们就要想一想，
我们造这东西到底是为什么？
不够的时候是很简单的，
就你拼命造就行了。
所以你拼命奋斗到底是图上啊？
对。
我感觉这是一个社会现在各个层面，
各个群体，
大家都在思考的一件事情。
就是富起来之后的第一个，
就是人在即可的时候是没那么多问题的。
我们现在终于有资格来想这个问题了。
从国家层面也好，
从个人层面也好，
也就是这两三年以来才有这个资格。
这里面有几个变化，
就第一个呢，
就是刚才说的AI的变化，
第二个刚才说的这个生产力，
我们终于到了一个节点说，
以前只要无脑生产就行了。
与你不够的时候是简单的。
但是当够了之后，
你就要想结构目标，
为什么？
然后愿景到底是什么？
就这些复杂的问题一下就来了。
然后这里面有一个表征是什么呢？
就是你会看到现在的。
所有的投资的资产价格也好，
企业决策和个人的决策也好，
与基本面的短期数据，
出现了非常历史性的背利。
这个我解释一下，
就说GDP,
不论长跌短期的长跌，
涉荣涉灵这些原本我们一直在观测的。
高频经济数据，
不论他们的变化怎么样，
股票该涨还是涨，
与这些数据没关系。
黄金该涨还是涨，
房子该跌还是跌。
这些高频数据以前是对这些资产价格。
是有非常紧密的影响的。
一个数据出来了好坏了，
就会马上影响到这个产业的股价，
或者马上影响到这些投资的风向。
但是现在我们的最近两年的观察就是，
短期的续世，
没有太多人在看。
大家看的都是那些宏大的东西，
就是未来远景的，
你看投资现在投的都是，
AI、机器人、半导体，
以十年为周去去思考这件事情。
然后人生的决策也是，
未来三个月怎么样，
就是好像没有那么让人着急，
但是未来三年十年的事情，
大家很忧虑很慌。
就像你前面说的这个波风波谷，
就是每一波浪来，
大家都害怕自己是被拍死的那一群人。
嗯，是这样，
就是大家都担心被抛下，
就是你刚才说的，
一方面担心停下。
担心缩圈自己没有跑到圈里面。
没有没在圈里面，
被遗留在圈外，
但是圈外也没有什么不好啊。
是,
我觉得按照我们刚才的推演，
我觉得未来的工作是很恐怖的，
就是你看我们讲，
之前在执笔时代，
就可能是我们爸妈的那个年代，
他们的工作非常的从容不破，
中午有空回家做饭，
上班就是看完报纸喝茶，
偶尔处理点工作，
然后也不需要加班，
甚至还能去跟同时打打牌，
跳跳舞，
然后后面后来往时代，
就是人类的悲欢无法相同，
他们其实理解不了我们为什么看起来这么疲惫。
对。
对，包括像今年过年，
就很多人说年味淡嘛，
就我觉得我回去，
我就能感受到自己全身心的对过年这件事情的排斥。
好，为什么？
我就觉得，
为什么从早到晚一直在搞卫生，
为什么所有东西都要插起来洗一遍，
所有的地都要拖一遍，
我说大家就不能安静一点，
大家好好休息一下嘛，
就好不容易有一个这么长的假，
为什么不能好好休息一下，
但是你能感觉到家里的长辈们，
魂身是有使不完的扭劲的。
对。
只有他们有劲儿去搞大扫厨，
贴春莲儿或者干这些东西，
我就只想躺着。
对。
那你想到未来，
就是你现在我们就已经是在靠外卖行业，
靠各种的跑腿啊以及其他的服务，
来免利支撑我们这样的一个遥遥郁坠的这样的一个个人的小系统。
那到了AI时代，
他对于你经历心理时间的占据和消耗，
我觉得是无法估量的。
蛮好估量的，
其实很简单，
你看啊，
现在那个外卖啊送达时间已经比较准确了。
对。
往往不会差很多，
然后每次都卡着那个上线给你送了。
对。
对吧,
为什么？
这个就是他能力的上线了。
你以后也会有一个羽白算法的。
就是我的老板也能看到我的上线。
对,
然后会有一个算法给你。
那我的工作时间会变得可空吗？
你就像外卖小哥一样，
就是他虽然时间有一个羽白算法，
他能算出比如说我工作交付的时间。
对。
但是这段时间我的疲惫度，
我对我心里经历的消耗，
它是没保养的。
就让你到极致嘛，
就外卖小哥都在极致。
就是我觉得那个时候，
难道不会出现大面积的精神崩溃吗？
呃,
如果有一亿人出现这个问题的话，
你就不用操心这个问题了。
就是你一个人的问题是你的问题，
一亿人的问题你就放心睡觉，
会有人来解决的。
就像当青少年异域，
如果成为一个更普遍的问题。
对,
大家学就放假了。
哎呀,
太地域了啊。
然后到时候也许真的有一天，
因为种种原因，
各种考量，
我们开始实行类似于一周四天工作制之类的。
呃,
嗯,
那我们的灵活都可以吗？
大家都是儒家文化圈的。
就是会有一天的，
如果人类不断的进步的话，
会有一天大家会，
物质真的极大充分，
能源问题得到了某种意义上的充分解决之后，
我们的子孙后代或许有一天，
他真的是为了爱好去工作，
或者工作变成一种特权，
你只有特别被选中的人才能工作。
这个是很多人讨论AI取代人类工作，
大家幻想的美好途径，
就是大家可以凭着自己的爱好和兴趣去工作，
甚至还得去付费工作。
这其实已经是一个偏乐观的预测。
就是现在已经在工作，
发现已经意识到工作让人不舒适的这群人，
估计是不太能看得到那一天。
因为你现在已经开始工作，
意味着你已经二十多岁了，至少。
所以你是预测这个未来，
它有可能来，但是没有那么快？
不会那么快的。
更快时间的未来是AI来给你建功。
这个是一定是很快的。
包括机器人这个东西，
大家觉得好像已经开始跳舞了。
实际上机器人能够全面参与到我们的社会当中来，
它还需要大概五到十年支持一个比较乐观的判断。
OK。
但机器人进来之后，不代表你就不用干活了。
啊，我以为机器人是一个比AI更能彻底替代我的？
没有，它是一个你的工具，
它是你的生产工具。
就像以前你用一个铫头，
现在给了你一个拖拉机，
你就要去更更多的地。
我觉得听到这里可能很多人会很迷惑，
那就像前面说的，
现在一个人带着一堆AI工具能跟二十个人的活，
那剩下的十九个人在AI时代他们去干嘛呢？
每个人都干二十个人的活。
有这么多活吗？
这就是总需求上位满足的前提，
就是老板就会拼命地让你干更多啊。
我觉得上次跟一飞老师吃饭的时候，
他有提到一句话，
他说人的欲望是无止境的。
在某个程度上对。
对，就是他当时举的例子是说，
大家觉得现在的生活水平都很好，
没有什么更多的想要追求的，
他说其实不是这个样子。
假如当所有人都乘坐私人飞机出行的时候，
你会不会觉得坐高铁是件难以忍受的事情？
是，没错。
当有钱人都能活到150岁的时候，
那你会不会觉得我只能活到80岁？
是一件很不公平的事情？
人类的快乐不来源于富足，来源于优越。
在我们的评论区其实还有不少听有反驳，
所以我就不跟别人比较啊，
我从来不跟别人比较。
就是因为如果你不跟别人比较，
你要知道我们人类的人均寿命超过40岁，
也不过100年而已。
在此之前，大部分的时间，
人类的大部分的社会都是卡路里的社会严重不足的，
会饿死人的情况。
那实际上如果你在当今的社会，
你已经具备了100年之前一个中产以上的人的生活水平。
这洛克菲勒都没有你过的好现在？
对，所以你按道理，
你现在是可以完全什么也不用干的。
如果你真的不跟别人比较，
你现在是饿不死的，
或者你只要非常简单的一个基础的工作，
你真的能够忍受这样的生活吗？
你现在的这个假设是基于现在当下社会你要水，
要电，要互联网，
就这些东西你现在看是理所当然的，
因为你要抓到手机，
移动互联网也就是十几年的事情。
对，你现在已经觉得这是理所当然的，
你不可以没有。
那十年以后出来的新东西你可能也不可能没有，
只我们现在不知道那是什么。
所以这个就是总需求上位完全满足的第一阶段，
我觉得大家不用觉得我就一定会失业了。
嗯，因为包括我们前面其实一直在讲说，
随着 ASL 到来，
可能大家的工作时长会变得更长，
强度会变得更大，
以及就是我们说，
随着技术的进步、经济的发展，
我们的欲望它其实也是在层层加码的。
当然这个听起来好像是很坏的事情，
但是如果我们换个角度想，
随着这些欲望的增大，
它其实也会诞生非常多的工作机会，
它可能会创造很多新的需求。
对，我刚才说的一个人干二十人的活，
不是说你现在的工作当下的工作干二十人的活，
它可能会有其他的工作。
由于新的生产力的诞生，
导致原本不可想象的事情得到了实现，
然后就会产生新的工作，
产生新的可能。
当然会有一些结构性的东西，
比如说你是一个司机，
然后你只会开车。
那么这个就叫结构性的损失。
这就需要刚才说的大的机制去调节它。
实际上就是 UBI 嘛，
就是全民基本收入这样的东西。
所以技术的进步会带来生产力的提高，
也会造成劳动者工作时长和付出心力各方面的增长，
就是增加它的疲惫。
然后这些疲惫并不会导致生产关系的变化，
让它们有更多的休息时间，
而是诞生了更多的经济机会。
这是完整的逻辑链吗？
足够疲惫到变成一个社会问题的时候，
它就会得到解决。
那这有指标吗？
有一些基础的观测指标，
比如说，当然我不知道这个能不能讲，
就是现在其实有一些在观测失业，
然后包括舆论的监测社会的稳定的一些指标，
就这些东西其实是有相关部门在看的。
这些数据呢，实际上我们说这个稳发展叫六稳六保吧，
就稳定性上面的一些指标是很核心的指标。
然后这个数据一旦产生比较大的波动的时候，
我们就会有对应的政策出来做抖底。
但是个体的或者是一小部分人的悲欢离合，
它并不会当做一个纳入考量的事情。
足够多的时候会汇聚成一个不得不许听到的声音。
或者还是人太多了，就你崩了，
就是你不干有的是帕鲁干。
那你说海外其实也面临这样的就业和失业的问题？
嗯。
对，就比如德国，刚才我们再举个例子，
它如果再不转变，它如果还这么慢，
它可能接下来就会被弄走更多的工作。
因为现在德国很多的工厂就搬到中国来嘛。
对。
以前这个大众叫再中国为中国，
现在叫再中国为世界，
意味着大众的研究和生产工厂放在了中国，
然后向全世界去出口，
德国的工厂就会关闭，
那么德国的工人就会失业。
那德国的工人就会抢，
刚才你说的餐厅里面的那些员工的饭碗，
然后这个时候老板就有了选了。
所以他们可能也是在一个临界点附近？
对呀，总理回去就已经着急了嘛。
那作为个体的话，
作为一个生活在中国的个体，
面临这样的一个即将到来的时代，
它有什么自己更好的应对的方法吗？
我这个真的是一个很难的问题，
就是你必须要找到自己，
刚才你说的有一个朋友他说我不跟别人比，
那我要过好我的生活，
如果你真的能够在内心找到这种程度的平静的话，
其实你的压力没那么大了。
说完了，你如果在中国，
你只想要一口饭吃不饿死，
其实你是不需要这种抢脱的工作的。
你也不需要如此焦虑去学员。
对，就是如果你真的说我只要不饿死，
只要有一个小房间，
然后有一个网线，
我就能活下去的话，
如果你真的能够说服自己到这个地步的话，
那其实中国是做得到的。
但是如果你要更多的话，
那确实就是要参与到这个缩圈的竞赛当中。
就要拼命奔跑，
然后来维持停留在原地。
对，好残酷，
我们最后能给一个光明点的结尾吗？
我觉得这个蛮光明的，
就是你要意识到相对的变化，
你也许是维持在原地，
但绝对变化，
你是肯定是进步的，
而且是非常指数级的进步。
就你想象一下，
中国二十年前和中国现在，
你相对而言，
可能仍然不是社会中最有钱的那批人，
对吧?
但是你的生活水平在过去的二十年，
三十年当中已经得到了非常跨越的发展。
二十年前的中国是什么样？
2006年,
三十年前是1996年，
那个时候我们可能刚刚没有再用粮票，
然后刚刚可以满足一个基本的粮食的重配，
你完全可以吃饱饭，
但可能吃肉还不能够百分之百的带来都能吃饱，
住的就是非常小的房子。
现在减肥是个热门的话题，
这在人类历史上也是绝无疾忧的。
然后你手机就不说了，
那时候连电视都很稀罕，
加拿大汽车这种事情在二三十年前就是很难想象，
那现在实际上都已经发生了，
但是你觉得，
哎，我怎么还是在这个社会上面过得就很一般，
那是你原来横向比较吗？
嗯,
但是不管怎么样，
我觉得我们还是给大家报了一个好消息，
就是不用担心失业。
对,
或者这样说，
就是如果你觉得你是一个平常人，
普通人，
那么如果当一个普通人都面临着非常极端的就业威胁的时候，
这个问题就不应该由你来解决。
对,
所以不要给自己那么大的压力。
对，这就不是你的问题，
就不应该由你来解决。
嗯,
那如果你想要更多，
想要成为人上人，
那这是你的问题。
那这个解决问题的方法有两种，
一种是，
就是调整自己的心态。
嗯,
就不要去追求那种被超越性存在的机身。
另外一种呢，
就是你就去卷那个缩圈，
你就非得当这个人，
我就非要当第一。
嗯,
我就非要比别人过得好。
对,
就是我觉得那种担忧啊，
就是这种焦虑是真不用，
因为焦虑刚才说的就是焦虑的来源是，
你觉得你可以改变这一切。
我们首先告诉大家的是这个，
你不能够改变这一切，
然后呢，
也不该你去改变这一切，
真的产生这种社会型的问题的时候，
就是会有人来解决这些问题。
我觉得现在就是信息奔用的年代，
因为拥有太多信息，
他会给你知道一个错觉，
觉得是我应该承担这一切，
我应该负所有的责任，
我应该去解决这些问题，
但其实并非如此，
所以不需要给自己这么大的包袱和压力。
嗯,
没错。
对，以及就是希望大家照顾好自己，
尽可能的。
特别是不要在疲惫的时候和饥饿的时候做决定。
嗯。
人的同理心和理智在血糖低的时候会被极度压缩，
然后你会非常的冲动意怒，
所以在疲惫和低血糖的时候，
晚上的时候不要做重大的决策。
嗯。
这个是一个小建议。
不要在深夜且饥饿的时候开始回想说，
哎呀，我怎么没有赶上这些浪潮啊。
是。
开始陷入无尽的懊悔和焦虑当中，
不如睡个好觉。
对。
嗯。
好的,
先谢谢易飞老师。
好，谢谢你。
以上就是本期节目的全部内容。
如果你觉得这一期节目有收获，
有启发，
欢迎你把它转发给你关心的亲友，
也许会对他有帮助。
这一期节目坦白说，
可能不是那种听完之后，
会让人马上觉得轻松下来的内容，
我们也没有试图在最后给出一个很漂亮的结论。
比如说，
没关系，
技术最终会解决一切，
AI会创造很多新工作，
所以大家不需要担心。
比起给出一个好听的答案，
我们更想做的，
是试着去解释一种越来越普遍的感受。
为什么在技术不断进步，
效率不断提高的时代，
可我们却没有因此得到更多的休息。
为什么很多时候，
我们拼命努力，
拼命提升自己，
到最后争取到的，
可能只是一个可以继续更努力的机会。
如果是这样，
那这里面大概确实有些地方出了问题。
可我相信，
把这一点看清楚，
本身不是一件坏事，
因为很多时候，
最让人感到辛苦吃力的，
不只是辛苦本身，
而是你一边辛苦工作，
一边还是会忍不住怀疑，
是不是自己不够努力，
不够清醒，
不够适应这个时代。
可当你把这些东西稍微看明白一点之后，
也许就能把夹在自己身上的那些压力，
慢慢卸下来一点点。
你会逐渐意识的，
很多疲惫和焦虑，
并不只是个体的问题，
它的背后，
确实有很大结构性的原因。
也正因为如此，
当越来越多的人，
都开始感到疲惫，
开始感到不安，
开始意识到，
好像哪里不太对的时候，
外部也不会永远没有反应。
无论是政策层面，
开始尝试提振消费，
改善预期，
还是整个社会，
慢慢重新开始讨论休息，
讨论工作，
讨论什么样的生活才值得我们去过。
我觉得，
这些变化其实都已经在发生了，
他们可能来的不够快，
也不够彻底，
但至少说明，
这种普遍性的疲惫，
不是你的错觉，
也不只是你一个人的问题。
所以这一期节目最后留给我们的，
可能不是一个振奋的答案，
而是一个提醒。
不是只有跑进那套最激烈的竞争里，
我们的生活才有价值。
也不是没有跟上每一轮浪潮，
我们的人生就失败了。
对我们来说，
更重要的是弄清楚，
自己到底想要什么样的生活。
什么东西，
真的值得我们投入那么多的力气。
只是因为周围所有人都在追，
所以我们也在被裹挟着往前走。
努力这件事本身，
不能只是为了让我们。
获得一个可以更加努力的资格。
如果努力到最后，
只是让自己越来越累，
那我们也确实需要停下来问一问，
这样的努力，
究竟是在成全我们的生活，
还是在一点一点的吞掉它。
如果你喜欢执行小酒馆，
请别忘记订阅我们的节目，
这会成为我们继续前行的重要动力。
我是羽白，
每周晚8点，
我们在执行小酒馆，
不见不散。